we
became very familiar with mark meadows
wait so you literally have that at home
[Music]
is she in the green room yet do we know
i don't see her security
no she is okay she is
talking
okay
so
okay
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
okay
um
[Music]
[Music]
good morning earlier this week the
speaker of the house
issued a statement on the floor of the
house
that we would have a rules change that
when members
were on the floor they must always be
wearing a mask
except when they were speaking we have
understood from all of you that as long
as i keep my distance from you
which i fully intend to do
that i can abide by the house
floor rule on this store as you all know
yesterday there was the president had a
bipartisan meeting
of the congressional leadership uh it
was very positive i think the tone of it
was very appropriate to the important
work that we have to do very proud of
what the president is presenting a big
bold plan
uh to build back better for our country
and significant part of that is building
the infrastructure of our country
how you define infrastructure is part of
how we go forward
we don't want to define it in an old
way we want to be thinking in terms of
the future
but again we'll see how far
we can go working together
bipartisanship has
always been the hallmark of our work on
uh building the infrastructure of our
country it has never
been uh something that we have not come
to terms
in the obama administration the bill was
smaller than i would have liked
but when you think that it was
negotiated between barbara boxer and
senator barbara boxer and senator inhofe
although yesterday senator mcconnell
injected that with boxer and mcconnell
who came to the
final agreement on that bill and that is
a
shall we say uh that was progress but we
want more
and uh that's what we're here to do the
con there's
recognition uh that the country needs
a strong infrastructure package uh uh
you know
look no further than the american
society of civil engineers
which gives us a d a d c minus depending
on the
uh the category of infrastructure
they're addressing
it it's an issue of commerce it's an
issue of clean air
it's an issue of quality of life for
people to
have them out of their cars with more
mass transit and the rest and it is also
an issue of um
just again growth in a way
that is about safety as well as jobs
safety issues in mr mcconnell's state
alone there are like a thousand
bridges uh that are insecure
and well i could go state by state on
that
in any event it is
we look forward to working as much as
possible in a bipartisan way
and i salute the president as i began my
comments doing
uh for the goal that he has set the tone
in which he has conducted the discussion
the and well i won't say endless because
i'm not there for them
the series of meetings he's having with
members of congress
in a bipartisan way and i think today's
meeting with the
republican of senators some of the
republican senators
once again so he's making every attempt
and i think it is bearing fruit
uh we'll see again
we're very proud of what happened when
we pass the
recup the rescue package but in order
for people to
avail themselves of the benefits of it
they have to know
right now we're in the course of a
child tax credit week of action
week of action before we had day of
action for one aspect of the bill or
another
this is a week of action because it
leads up to may 17th which is the day
that we're encouraging people to file
their income tax forms even if they are
below the level of having to file a tax
return because in order to get the tax
credit refundable you need to buy your
tax return
so i'm very very proud of the work
that's being done and
i've been involved in a series of those
meetings and many of the
community groups who have the confidence
culturally linguistically in so many
ways with so many
people in our community are helping a
great deal
they're helping a great deal also in
terms of vaccines in the arms
money in the pockets children in school
as well as workers going back to work to
communicate with the community
members of the community who might have
been previously
underserved then as i say we go on to
the jobs bill and that's
that's i think that's pretty pretty
exciting uh
adjusting on the tax credit since we're
having tax credit
child tax credit week of action
it will benefit 27 million families
and cuts child poverty in half
cuts child poverty in half and that's
kind of remarkable
so as we again build back better
we think that it's important for us to
have um more women
in the workforce shall we say that that
child child care is very
important to that that we have uh
workforce development so that people can
be trained
for these jobs as we build in a more
future resilient futuristic
resilient way and that's why this
package has a
an integrity to it a oneness that says
if we're going to build that better
if we're going to have many more people
involved both in the job creation and
the equity
that could come from contracts and the
rest for women
veterans people of color rural areas and
the rest
that we have to be more open to many
more people being involved
and for that to happen the
transformative measure
is child care elder care care for our
people with disabilities so in terms of
child care
children learning parents earning in
terms of the others
people being able to go into the
workforce with the comfort of knowing
that their loved one is
cared for and that goes with the respect
that we would have
for the workforce to get that done so
i'm very excited about
everything that the president is putting
forth uh it's
to me it's like the promised land of so
many good things
but of course i want more but but that's
the president has modulated his um
his proposal in a way that hopefully
will be as bipartisan as possible
as green as possible and as soon as
possible
the other subject i'm going to bring up
today with you is what
what is on the floor today we have the
this uh built on the floor that means a
lot to me as a mother of five
uh that's the pregnant workers fairness
act a bipartisan step to ensure
that women are no longer forced to be
between
the health of healthy pregnancies and
their paychecks
any family members in the room know
that the blessing of of a
a child coming into the family should
not be jeopardized by any heavy lifting
on the job but that's to put it uh
simply i'm especially pleased
that it's going to be strongly
bipartisan and i'm excited about that
personally as well as officially
i want to talk a little bit about some
security issues that we're
hoping to bring to the floor next week
one of them is the
supplemental uh rosa de la chair of the
appropriations committee
may be prepared to file that today it's
in the works and that would come up in
rules next week and to the floor
it's very essential that we get going
with that in my view it's overdue
but nonetheless uh it is uh
it's urgently needed now uh it benefits
from the
report of general honore and the cadre
of
people both from law enforcement and
from
national security who made
recommendations about how to secure the
capital
how to strengthen the police force how
to have us return
to a capitol where visitors can come
children
can experience our democracy
you all can cover it worker our workers
can safely do their jobs here our
custodial staff
feel safe and that members can serve
sadly yesterday there was a hearing in
the committee on government reform
that was quite appalling i there's no
use my even telling you about it you
have to see it for yourself because
you would not believe that a republican
member on the committee
said that what happened that day was
just
the normal orderly visit of people to
the capitol
really really well i don't know
on a normal day around here when people
are threatening
to hang the vice president of the united
states or shoot the speaker in the fire
uh or disrupt uh and injure so many
uh police officers uh i i don't consider
that normal multiple people were killed
over 140 police officers
issued a gallows was put up and the
attackers
hanged the vice president normal
yet in a hearing held yesterday some
house republicans
defended those actions saying the
rioters were orderly
and acting similar to a normal
tourist visit they basically
saw them they said well they were just
walking through between the
the velvet ropes that are there to to
direct
tourist the taurus path you have to see
it because
it was beyond denial it fell into the
range of sick
and uh that's what we have to deal with
when we are saying it's urgent for us to
secure the capital
why it was just a normal tourist day we
have to
strengthen our police force why it was
just a normal tourist day
and we have to establish a commission
for january 6th why
it was just a normal tourist day the
same denial
that has they've acted upon in terms of
our colleague congresswoman liz cheney
the denial that they have there
the denial about what happened that day
the denial for the need for more
security to
make sure it doesn't happen again and
the denial of refining the truth
is what we have to deal with and we will
find the truth
and we're hoping that we can do so in
the most bipartisan way possible
i think that that's essential but i
think it's also important
to the american people to have
confidence in the results
of such an investigation what else do we
want to talk about here now
the at the beginning of our meeting
yesterday the president talked about
the cyber attack on the colonial
pipeline
as you know then last night or was that
this morning he issued
an executive order very important
and something that hopefully we can
codify when we
get to a place where um
we would have the votes to do so but for
the time being an executive order
really the first point of it encouraging
the private sector to share information
with the um with the
the government so that we know what the
threats
are in real time there are threats
quite a bit and uh and they are
this what happened yes the other day was
not damaging the pipeline it was a
threat to the pipeline but the company
decided
to shut it down to make sure that they
could proceed now they have
as i put early this morning they've
decided to open it up again
and according to the secretary of of
energy
that they think should be normal
tomorrow the next day the next day but
certainly by the end
of the weekend uh we are going to
there was a briefing for members last
evening
as more information becomes available
that was an unclassified briefing
but essentially
most of what we know is in in the in the
public domain
any questions on any other subject
yes um on the meeting yesterday at the
white house
um can you tell us did you hear anything
surprising from the republican
leadership about the infrastructure plan
perhaps on how to pay for it just
anything surprising to women
well your question is an interesting one
because my motto is i'm never surprised
around here no i'm never surprised uh
almost yesterday but i'm never surprised
uh and not at the meeting but at the
committee meeting no i think it was
pretty um
regular but you know mitch mcconnell
doesn't want to pay
open up the tax scam of 2017.
um kevin was more conventional in terms
of what you would i'm excuse me leader
mccarthy was more conventional
and when when you talk about what is
infrastructure
i think it was a pretty standard fear in
that regard
um it was as to say the president was
clear he wants bipartisanship
he wants as much as possible soon
and closer in terms of the amount that
we would be investing
and it was polite courteous
pleasant almost
the one thing that was brought up and i
mentioned this in a press event after
what yesterday
was uh so what other pay fors are there
that
doesn't mean we were the president has
said we're
nobody making under 400 000
a year is going to have his or her taxes
raised
and he's consistent with that uh some
other sources of funding
uh include uh the
people that are not paying taxes now
we all know it's reported that 50
uh corporate major corporations in our
country paid no
taxes last year none zero
but they did that by the manipulation of
the laws i mean
i'm not talking about them they should
pay more and that's
something that we have to talk about but
what president was
referencing was the people who are
illegally
avoiding taxes i'm not saying ethically
or moral
i'm talking about illegally avoiding
taxes
and then my understanding is
it's at least a trillion it could be a
trillion a quarter trillion and a half
dollars of illegally unpaid
taxes in the country so the and part of
the answer is to beef up
uh the um irs so they could take in
uh those taxes and that's a big chunk
that was that would go a long way
we didn't uh separate from the meeting
we didn't go into it but as you know the
chair of our ways and means committee
richie neil
has some ideas about building build
american bonds and that but we
we really didn't go into that
clearly yesterday in the oversight
committee there were several members of
the republican conference who doubted
what happened on january 6th or
downplayed what happened on january 6th
then in the evening we had an
interaction between margaret taylor
green
and alexander cortez where mgb
sort of went after her and sort of
parading her in the hallway
i'm wondering just generally is there a
sense that
your members are safe here at the
capitol do you have concerns about
here on the hill it feels like things
are just more contentious
well i i think that what you it was
reported to our office
about what happened uh as members were
leaving the floor yesterday
uh the verbal assault and real abuse
of our colleague congresswoman uh
uh aoc
the it's so beyond
the pale of anything that is in keeping
with bringing honor
to the house or not bringing dishonor to
the house
it's so beyond the pale that you wonder
is this
it probably is a matter for the ethics
committee
uh but that's up to someone i i've
always kept the
leadership offices separate from any um
motions to take anything to ethics but
as one who served on the ethics
committee for seven years
six years is the maximum they asked me
to serve another year
that's how i paid my dues to the caucus
this is beneath the dignity of a person
serving in the congress of the united
states
and is a cause for trauma and fear among
members
especially on the heels of an
insurrection on which the
majority of which the majority in the
excuse me the minority in the committee
yesterday
denied ever happened it didn't happen
i don't know if you saw last night the
the body camera i think cnn had the
body camera um
video of officer fernand
it is stunning if you haven't seen that
you have to see that because
it was such an abuse
battling a police officer now he's a
metropolitan police officer i have met
with him
he's trying to meet with the republican
leader i hope that that would happen
uh but when these people were yesterday
saying they were just friendly to the
police and all that
sick that's just only one word so
that this is not behavior that is i i
could
give you chapter and verse of many other
things that they have done
that being the most recent and very
egregious
and not in keeping with the behavior of
a member of congress and their own
caucus their own caucus uh should
exercise
some discipline is not the word
uh respectable behavior standard
for them but it could be that this would
rise the level of an ethics uh complaint
i mean yes you talked about the pipeline
yes colonial decline the ransom we know
there are
issues larger than we felt with the dc
police pack as well
obviously president put out his
executive order last night
but should these firms and it's a
question whether it's a private matter
or republican because they've served so
much of the public
should these firms be alpowing to these
terrorists to pay these ransoms
especially on the scale of what colonial
and what you've done what's the question
should these firms win what should they
be should they be paying for
no okay so what do you so did you
disagree with them
with the ransom today well the point is
is that we don't
want people to think that uh there's
money in it for them to
threaten the security of a critical
infrastructure in our country
uh i'm not i again
they made their decision but really
because
the of the service to the public that
this
is is we we've made drastic
adjustments we've waived the jones act
so that patrol
ships carrying petroleum can come to
certain ports in our country to
to keep the supply going that's a big
deal
uh so to the extent that we know
especially in advance
what might be happening and again i
think that we have to look to
this is shall we say russian
oriented we don't know
putin oriented uh but they don't even
deny
it you know the perpetrators of this
don't even deny it
so we have a responsibility in three
ways
one security that's the oath we take
protect and defend
this is a secure security issue two
economics this is an economic issue the
dependence on
uh energy as we know people
personally but business-wise depend on
that
and three a governance issue
a governance issue this cannot be uh
open season for hackers
who can make money off of a threat
even if they don't go as far as
crippling
uh the entity that that as as with
colonial they did not
uh so it is uh it has to be subject to
review
i don't know what the conversations were
with the uh management of colonial
but i do think uh that there is a pub
a governance role in how we protect our
people
and our economy uh from these these
hackers
the president has been criticized
including by democrats for not doing
enough to de-escalate
the violence in the middle east there
was a readout of his call yesterday with
netanyahu in which he said israel has a
right to defend
itself but there was no mention it seems
at least of the palestinians nor
any apparent criticism of what many see
as a disproportionate response
by israel i wonder what your reaction is
to that should
could the president and the us be doing
more i think the president took the
appropriate
proportionate uh response to it all uh
the fact is is that we have a
very close relationship with israel and
israel's security is a national security
issue for
us as our friend a democratic country in
the region
that the president has restored the
money to the palestinians 200
million dollars early in his
administration
so there's a respect for meeting the
needs of the palestinians
uh but there is a palestinian power
struggle and this is about hamas
so i wouldn't just label it palestinian
i would say hamas
and hamas is
threatening the security of people in
israel israel has
a right to defend itself many of our
members in our caucus who
are great friends of israel but
understand
also that we respect the
self-determination that we want a
two-state solution in the region
but that doesn't give license to hamas
to bomb
israel speaker
thank you the latest border patrol
report shows a
deterioration in the border situation
more interdictions do you think vice
president harris is in the best position
to exert
her presence there too to fix things
yeah well first of all let me just uh
correct the record here i don't know
what aspect of
the border you're talking about but the
record uh the
figures that came out in april showed
that eight there was an
eighty percent decrease of the number of
of children in the in the under the
um auspices of the border patrol
six thousand something to one thousand
something they had been
moved out more expeditiously than before
because
the biden harris administration had
reconstructed
how we deal with the situation at the
border
as i have said on the border three r's
three r's what are the roots of this
immigration and that's
where the vice president has been tasked
uh to
i don't know visit physically but
communicate directly
with the governments of the northern
triangle el salvador guatemala and
honduras
i think she is very well suited
to do that secondly roots
second are reconstruct you had to
deconstruct
the horrible situation that the trump
administration
had created at the border deconstruct it
so you can reconstruct a better system
and they have and the third is uh
my our friends the refugees as i've said
to you all before you've heard it you
can repeat it i'm sure because you've
certainly said over and over again that
when we had a hearing on this subject
the evangelical said that
the us the united states refugee
resettlement program
is the crown jewel of american
humanitarianism
this is something now i'm pleased that
the president has
raised the number of people who can come
into our club
every country has a moral responsibility
to help those excuse me in fear
of persecution or danger where
uh in their other their home country
so i think that did come up in our
meeting yesterday
uh because i was mentioning that when i
uh took a group right before clovis say
about 15 or i don't know
year and a half ago about uh to the
northern triangle
to the countries i mentioned el salvador
guatemala and honduras
recognizing from previous visits and to
the border over and over again
at that violence
economic hardship but that's not a cause
for pros
uh amnesty but nonetheless a reason why
somebody might leave home
violence and corruption and all those
things
were what were causing people to flee
but what i
learned in that more recent visit was
that the climate issue was habit and the
drought was having such an impact
on the agricultural industry there that
people were
lost their livelihoods they lost their
jobs they lost their
ability to farm and not only were they
losing
their ability to produce food they were
hungry themselves
so the sec the mountain vice president
said that she has had engaged the
secretary of agriculture to be part of
that
so it's secretary vice president i'm so
proud of her
vice president harris but with the
resources
of the biden harris administration
get to the root cause of it reconstruct
the
system that was there so that it works
better
and third understand our responsibility
to refugees the three r's i will say in
that conversation the president
was totally knowledgeable chapter and
verse
very concerned and something i think
that he deals with
uh every day
i just want to ask you on the
supplemental web whether you believe
um there's agreement with republicans on
it and secondly on
um the january 6 commission whether you
believe there's any
whether you plan to put on the floor
next week and whether you believe
there's any
movement in the negotiations
on the latter i thought was the latter
i'm optimistic
that we have come
closer in terms of of the uh
the negotiation about a commission
and if you look at 911 and the rest what
you want to do is
who makes that up what is the makeup of
the commission
okay they wanted it to happen half now
mind you most commissions that we've
formed since then
have enabled the president to have have
uh uh appointments but nonetheless we've
come to a place
five and five the who
the how the subpoena power they had a
concern about
subpoena power okay we conceded on that
point
but we cannot concede on the
scope and that was sort of the last
stumbling block
uh because there was an interest and and
liz cheney
addressed that in her remarks this
i think this morning or last night but
it was reported this morning
about those in her own party who do not
want to keep this focused on january 6th
and they kept talking about what about
what happened last summer you know
black lives matter responses to george
floyd
uh murder for some reason antifa which
has nothing to do with any of this but
um
so we can't we're not going down that
path if they want to use 911
as their gold standard then we can't go
down that path
9 11 was about 9 11. and i really
thank you for the question and hope that
we will you will help
um spread the word
that this is a 9 11 type commission
i also add as one who was a
top democrat on the um intelligence
committee at the time
that at the time we did have a
congressional investigation
much of it preceded the 911 commission
and so i'm glad that our committees are
having their
their um their regular order
those with the jurisdiction uh in terms
of the security
issue but i also
believe that as with the 911 commission
that
whatever information they may produce
or law enforcement may produce as the
911 commission clearly spelled out
could be a resource uh to the commission
so am i do i believe yeah i believe
let me put a different way i am hopeful
that addressing the concerns they put
out there
uh but consistent with the purpose uh
that we should be able to have something
pretty soon in that regard we don't we
can always do a congressional
investigation
with full subpoena power in the hands of
the majority
and the um majority of members on the
committee
so so the vote would be for
subpoena or whatever now let's hope that
we don't have to go that route
i'm really as i said earlier it's
important for us to have it be as
bipartisan as possible
so the public has the most confidence in
the results of it
but you should be on the lookout for
though say we have something
soon immediately you have to appoint the
commissioners
there is a criteria for that that ups
they can't be members of congress or
elective office uh they
um have to be recognized figures in
terms of national security law
civil liberties there's a there's a
criteria as there was
in the uh 9 11 commission and
who they would appoint would be really a
sign
of their seriousness of the security of
our country
and seeking the truth on the uh
no i'm not i think yesterday was a step
forward
in terms of the uh infrastructure uh
again oh i'm sorry i thought you were
talking about that
a supplemental
one of the concerns i have from the
other side of the aisle
on the other day was letter that i got
from uh
leader mccarthy said why don't we just
do the supplemental
at the end of the year the end of the
year
a year from the insurrection
the end of the year well we can't no we
can't do that
so we will go forward with what was
recommended
this is very focused very
security at both in terms of physical
structure
and strengthening the police force and
the rest
based on what we've heard from general
honore and as i said before
the national security and law
enforcement experts that were on his
team
as well as what we've heard from the
inspectors general
in some of the hearings so this is very
now there are those who want to put this
that and the other thing on there
and that we think it just has to be
focused
on on its purpose which is uh
june 6. i'm sorry i thought you were
talking about the other thing
thank you
doesn't want to give any money or
doesn't want to give allow you to
receive communion your reaction to that
no i i think i can
use my judgment on that but uh um
i i'm pleased with what the vatican put
out on that subject did you read that
it'll be up to the individual priests no
it basically says
don't be divisive on the subject
thank you thank you you're ready for
this all night watching the warriors
earlier
are you ready for the cicadas are you
ready for the potato
apparently not get ready
i i'm hoping to go to one of the games
this weekend when i go home
i told my f my brother excuse me i told
my husband
that we had a nice father's day a month
early in store for him
we'll see we can get tickets anyway
thank you all thank you
constituents